In this video, I'm going to show you
everything you need to know about the
Ninja Trader webbased platform. From the
basics of just a chart setup to the
advanced tricks of setting up a ATM
strategy order for your active trading.
Now, first off, if you've never used
Ninja Trader, it's an extremely powerful
trading platform, and I'll leave a link
for it in the description below. Now,
the first thing you're going to do when
you set up Ninja Trader is you're going
to want to create the correct trading
data plan. Even to demo trade, you're
going to want to have real-time data.
Otherwise, it's delayed a lot of the
time. And the first thing to do that is
when you go to plans under account
settings, you're going to want to go to
your subscription. You might, if you
don't have anything, you're going to see
just create a subscription. Once you do
that, you're going to have a couple of
options. Now, they have two main options
up here. Generally, you're going to just
need the basic level one data. Level two
data is if you're really looking to go
into the order book. I don't personally
trade using that, but if that's
something you do, that's what you're
going to want to do. Now, I would
suggest going in here and instead of
just selecting include all market data,
customize it. Because what you can do
here is well they have a couple of other
options for very fancy data. But the
main thing is you can get the data
individually if you want to just trade a
couple markets. If you just want to
trade something like the CME which is
the main indexes like the NASDAQ
futures, oil futures, S&P 500 futures.
If you're not sure what's in there, you
can just click on the view products
button and it'll bring up this tab. And
so that will only cost you $4 a month
for doing level one of that. And so
that's what I would highly suggest if
you're looking to just trade a couple of
markets because that'll save you some
money consistently over time. And then
other than that, to get started, all you
have to do is just click this button
here or you can click this trade button
here on the left and that'll essentially
open up your account. And I'm just going
to launch simulated just so you know I
can mess around and kind of show you how
things work. And so what just came up is
the default that I just had that I was
messing around with. But initially,
you're going to have the default setup.
And what you probably want to do is you
want to exit out of every tab up here
because you're going to want to start
out with a blank setup just so you can
kind of start with settings that you
want and you can build out the platform
that you want to be using. And so the
main thing here is essentially at the
top here is your plus sign. Click new.
This is essentially how you can drag in
every type of module that they have. The
main one, of course, being charts. Now,
first off, I would say is go in here and
create new template. If you don't have
any, just type in a new one here and
click save. And it will essentially come
in here as that's the one you're working
on. And then it will save to that
constantly. Anytime you're setting it
up, it'll automatically save. So, every
time you come back in, it's the exact
same thing. And you don't have to
rebuild it. Now, once you drag that
blank chart, you can just click here and
either type in what you're looking for
or you'll have popular instruments pop
up. And so, here this is the ES futures.
And so, right away, this is kind of I
think their default chart or maybe what
I had default before, but you know, it's
not how I like it. And so, initially up
here, there's pretty
self-explanatory tools of okay, your
interval here is the time chart. If you
want, you know, a one minute chart, hour
volume range, you know, your options are
there. The type of candlesticks. I just
like normal candlesticks. And then you
have your configure button here. If you
have any indicators on there by default,
there's a simple moving average. I'm
just going to click the trash button to
remove that. And then you can also click
here to add indicators. It's really easy
to just go in here. They have them kind
of categorized. You can also click this
search button up here. And then also
they have community indicators which
brings up essentially a massive list of
you know the most popular ones but you
can also just filter or search for other
ones that are used and then you can see
you know how many times they're
downloaded and stuff like that. So those
are really nice if you have a community
one you're looking for. And then once
you have your chart saved how you
exactly like, you can create a template
so you can have your, you know, de day
trading or default chart setup. And so
again, it's saved every time and you
don't have to reset the settings to
exactly how you want. And so one thing
though, there's this chart setting
button I glossed over. This will allow
you to look at certain things going on
in the market. And so you can see
there's a couple things you can
essentially turn off or highlight them.
That's essentially means they're on.
Currently right now I'm in short like a
little position here. You can see it's
up almost $400. And the main thing is
there's also in here you can add other
things. I would highly suggest
essentially adding show order fill
lines, show trade lines, and then also
you don't have to do show fill lines
because that'll essentially show where
you got filled in your trades. But the
main thing is when you're actively
trading, and we'll get to that more in a
minute. Those are pretty important to
look at. Now, other super basic things
here is crosshairs. I have it the show
crosshair on default. I always just like
having that because it allows you to
kind of easily see where your mouse is,
especially compared to the yaxis and the
price of where the market currently is.
And then as well, you can do global. I
would suggest not doing global unless
you want to have multiple charts on the
same screen. Now, the kind of last
couple things here is data box. That's
just this little guy right here. You can
toggle that on or off. Now, to to move
it around, you have to click and drag on
the three dots in the top left.
Otherwise, you can't click and drag it.
That just shows the current candle that
you're moused over, not the current live
candlestick. It's the one that your
mouse is vertically over in terms of
where it is on the Xaxis. So, I don't
really find that super useful, at least
on a smaller time frame chart. And then
you have your drawing tools, your basic
drawing tools. And they're all pretty
self-explanatory. You know, for me, you
you have to click to toggle it and
thenclick to untoggle it. And then the
basics is you need to mouse over it
until you see that little circle pop up.
Double click it and then that brings up
your settings. And then what you need to
do or if you want to at least is make
sure to save as default if you have a
certain style for that that you like.
And then it'll come up the same every
time. And you can easily select it and
just click the delete button to remove.
A couple other settings here is in the
top right, you will see an H that
toggles hotkeys. And you'll see when
that's on, if you go all the way to the
left, there's this little keyboard thing
that pops up here. You can click disable
or just click retoggle to show that on
and off. And then there's also the view
settings. Essentially, all this does is
it's a couple other things here. One I
suggest to put on is bar countdown
settings. Just click enable. I wouldn't
put alerts on. All it does is it puts up
here at the top left next to what your
chart is essentially a countdown of the
time it will take until that bar is
finished forming. So really nice for
candlesticks that are based on time. And
another thing is trade mode. You'll see
that hides this main tab here. And so
for me, I like to trade on the chart.
And so I like to have that on there. Now
if you're trading on the DOM or
something, that's not necessarily as
important. And then as well here another
couple important things is you can roll
forwards the contract or roll backwards.
So just clicking that it will put it to
September. Obviously I'm in June right
now contract and so September really has
no volume on it and so definitely want
to roll back to the June. Now you can
see here it roll me back and the charts
all funky. Just click this arrow right
here at the top right that will appear
and it will reset your chart to the
basics. And so that's really simple if
for some reason it gets messed up. So to
get a new tab, you just leftclick this
new tab button. And let's say, okay, I
want to look at the NASDAQ now. And then
from there, I can just go to templates
and click day trading. Now, that chart's
a little messed up still. And I think
the candlestick sometimes doesn't change
on the template. It's a little funky,
but most of the settings are carried
over to go into a couple of other
things. is let's say you want to put in
you know let's say this market analyzer
and then also we can do the superdom
here as well and so what this will do is
now one thing is you can see there's
this little button next to it that you
can turn to different colors this is
essentially just how you can link
multiple charts together so that every
time you change one that it will go
through all of them. So right here, I
can just add a couple of charts to here
and say, "Okay, I want to look at the
NASDAQ and it'll bring up the NASDAQ on
all these three options, and it will
change the chart to how you want." Now,
one thing that might help too is for me,
my chart when I change it, it doesn't
load the chart properly. There's
something messing it up. And so, if you
go to chart settings here, you can tell
it to continue auto fit. And so, I can
put that on. And so because I have that
on and it's not working, it's probably
because of some indicator I have on. And
so that could happen if you put on an
indicator. And so I would put bars only.
And so it'll continuously do that as the
candlesticks move forwards. And so every
time a new candlestick is added, it'll
essentially auto fit again for you. And
you can see here as I drag it around, it
essentially auto fits the chart to what
how it makes sense. Now, you can have
this all on one screen or as well
another thing here is if you want to
maximize one chart specifically and look
at it, just this little button up here
and then to put it back to your main
setup, just click that unminimize again.
So, essentially that's this button up
here. Same thing with any of these, you
can maximize them and then bring them to
the smaller chart. Now, you don't have
to have it like this to where
everything's on one chart where you have
multiple charts here, you know, really
small and everything. You can as well
open up multiple tabs of this Ninja
Trader and then put them on a different
screen. I generally do that. So I would
suggest doing that as well. Um but you
know if you want one kind of one main
screen that is a good way to do it too.
Frankly I would suggest using the main
Ninja Trader desktop platform. But you
know if you're a Mac user or you feel
like this is important to use or you
just rather use this especially if
you're on the go definitely a good
option to use. But I will say the Ninja
Trader main platform is definitely
stronger. Now, let's get into setting up
your ATM strategy. This is super
powerful when it comes to trading. Now,
up here to turn this on, you know, you
need to turn on trade mode essentially.
And what that'll do is it allow you to
at a click of a button do a buy and sell
based on the chart. you know, you can
either put a sell limit order above the
market price or you can, you know, put a
buy stop above the market price and then
if you go below, it'll change to a sell
stop and a buy stop. So, it's super nice
in terms of that. And then you can just
say exit on these to close them out
really quickly. And so, just to kind of
start from scratch here as I have this
trade on it, you can all you can just
use these buttons to trade as well.
Super easy. I can just do close to close
out of that whole position. And you'll
see it it has this little line draw on
that and that is from if you go to the
chart settings here show trade lines. I
don't really think that is something
that I care to see but you know it's
kind of nice when you're trying to
visualize what you're trading. So if we
just kind of show all real quick to kind
of show you that'll show that. So to go
into the ATM strategy setup now you got
a couple of gears here. Now first off I
would do day generally for your trades.
Good to cancel means it's good until you
cancel it. So it's literally forever.
That's okay if you have a limit order
that you're trying to just see until it
gets filled and you know you're checking
it in every couple of hours or every
day. But so initially you're just going
to have this off here. And what you need
to do is click this gear button to bring
up this setting for it. Initially you're
not going to have any. So you need to
click this plus sign here to create one.
And so you know name it anything you
want. I would generally say, you know,
try and name it something that makes
sense because you're going to have
multiple. I like to do, you know, uh,
let's say a one:1 riskreward ratio with
a 40 tick stop-loss. And so what that
means is, you know, we'll go through
that in a minute is well, so the
settings here is show in ticks. I would
suggest doing ticks because that's
easily translatable through markets.
Now, you could do in terms of value if
you say, "Hey, I just want to have a
$100 stop-loss every time and a $100
profit target." That actually is makes a
lot of sense for that kind of trading.
But be aware that different markets will
have different sizes for that based on
how much their ticks are valued at. And
then, of course, the volatility of the
market will play in on that as well. And
then what you have here as well is you
can have a target profit and a stop-loss
which essentially means when I enter in
it puts in both of those or you can have
it just do one or the other. A lot of
the time just do a stop-loss only.
Mainly this is on the Ninja Trader
desktop platform, but those are options
in there as well to match what I kind of
put up here. This says 40 in the title.
So I'm going to do a 40 tick profit
target and a 40 tick stop-loss. And
essentially you can change it to a stop
which is just a stop market order or a
stop limit or or a trailing stop or an
even an auto break even even and a auto
break even trail stop. And so what it
does is it'll say hey if you're at let's
say 20 ticks in terms of profit target
it'll auto move your stop loss to break
even. I don't think that's a bad
necessarily way to trade but I don't do
that myself. And then there's also
things in here on how your auto break
even moves. Okay. So, I would suggest
when you're testing this out, always
test it on a demo account. Kind of see
how it plays around because you don't
want to be in a trade and you're not
really sure how that plays out.
Essentially, what this will do, this is
kind of a nice basic one. We'll just
click save. And then you want to go up
here and click the drop-own menu and
click the one you want. And then I'll
just say sell market here. And you can
see that it puts in the order right
here. The blue is where my trade
entered. And then down here is the
profit target and up here is the
stop-loss. And so you can see here it's
moving down pretty quickly. What you can
do with these as well. And so you can
see it just autofilled there basically.
Now what one thing to tell you to show
you here. So now here this is red
because I am essentially buying the
position versus if I close this out a
sell it's green and blue. So now what
you can do as well here with this is you
can move this around. So let's say oh I
want to move my profit target a little
further away or my stop loss a little
closer. You can move this around. So it
allows you to have a lot of
adjustability when you are trading. Now,
the other thing with this, if you want
to make it a little more advanced, if we
go back up to the gear here, we can edit
our current one and you can click this
plus sign. This essentially adds another
stop-loss and profit. And so,
essentially, the idea with this would be
is, okay, if I'm trading two contracts
in total, well, I want one to be, let's
say, a $80 take profit and one to be a
$40. And so to use this now, make sure
you put in the correct contracts that it
needs. That order needs two. So I'll
click buy market here. And you can see
that I have my two orders here for your
take profits. And then the one stop-loss
order here. Now you can see right now
they were over overlapped and it says
one next to it, but I know there's two
there. And so I have to click and drag
to see both of those. So, it's a little
confusing on the main Ninja Trader
desktop platform. These will combine so
you can kind of use one at both at the
same time versus having to drag them
separately. But grand scheme of things,
not too big of a deal. You just got to
remember that you know that there's two
right there. And then here you can see
there's the one split here and the other
one split there and then you know your
entries here. And as well you can see
the amount of money here. And so that's
really the main course of how this works
and how to unleash the power of this
platform. It's super useful for even
actively trading like this, either on
this chart style or using some of the
other features that they have. Now, if
you're just jumping into this, you
probably need a little bit of a
refresher and a detailed walkthrough on
how futures work and how to consistently
execute trading them on these platforms.
And so, check out this video right here.
It'll walk you through everything you
need to know about trading futures and
as well as how to get started with a
strategy on these platforms.